Madame la ministre,
1 article du Figaro
paru le 22/12 deux-mille-vingt-trois
témoigne de la situation bouleversante d'une
accompagnante d'élève en
situation de handicap,
diagnostiqué d'un cancer en avril deux-mille-vingt-deux,
Clotilde, à ush dans l'académie de Paris,
dépose 1 1ère arrêt maladie en mai.
Contractuelle de la fonction
publique depuis plus de 3 ans,
elle avait droit à 1 congé de maladie grave
et à l'intégralité de son salaire sur 1 an.
Cependant, le versement de son salaire est
suspendu dès le mois d'août deux-mille-vingt-deux.
Elle interpelle le rectorat de Paris
à de nombreuses reprises
mais ne reçoit de l'administration que des réponses
confuses et contradictoires,
voire pas de réponse du tout.
Quelques versements sont effectués sur son compte,
mais leur montant,
fort éloigné de ce qui lui est dû,
sont de plus irréguliers et incohérents.
À partir de son placement en soins paliatifs,
c'est sa famille qui prend le relais des démarches
administratives,
puis décide, face à l'inaction du rectorat,
de médiatiser sa situation.
Il y a tout juste 1 mois,
Clotilde est décédé des suites de sa maladie,
sans être rentré dans ses droits.
Ce dramatique exemple est
symptomatique de la précarité dans laquelle votre
ministère maintient les ush.
Mais il est également 1 alerte sur la maltraitance
institutionnelle
que constitue le traitement purement administratif,
trop souvent dénué de toute empathie,
des situations personnelles,
parfois douloureuses,
des agents de l'éducation nationale.
Je ne pense pas devoir vous rappeler que le salaire
moyen des ush,
moins de €900, est inférieur Au seuil de pauvreté,
que celles-ci,
essentiellement des femmes,
doivent faire face à l'augmentation du coup de la vie
et en particulier
dans les départements rureaux du coup des déplacements,
et que la généralisation des piales
à la rentrée deux-mille-vingt-et-un
a encore dégradé leurs
conditions de travail.
Vous le savez,
mon groupe parlementaire a porté 1 proposition de loi,
mais également de nombreux
amendements au projet de loi de
finance deux-mille-vingt-quatre
pour améliorer le statut
professionnel,
le salaire et les conditions de travail des AES H,
sans que ces propositions, pourtant nécessaires,
ne soient prises en compte par le gouvernement.
J'ai moi-même
alerté à plusieurs reprises vos prédécesseurs
sur le mépris
institutionnel ressenti par de très nombreux agents,
fonctionnaires ou contractuels de l'éducation nationale.
Mes questions sont donc les suivantes,
pouvez-vous me dire ce qui a été fait par le ministère
pour répondre à la détresse de la famille de Clotilde ?
Au-delà de ce cas particulier,
que comptez-vous mettre en place pour améliorer
réellement la situation
professionnelle des aesh ?
Et enfin,
que comptez-vous faire pour remédier ou lourdeur
administrative et à la gestion
trop souvent déshumanisée
qui affecte l'ensemble des salariés de votre ministère ?
Je vous remercie.
Merci, monsieur le député, madame la ministre,
monsieur le président, monsieur le député valtère,
les accompagnants d'élèves en situation de handicap,
les AES, ça joue 1 rôle essentiel
dans la scolarisation des élèves en
situation de handicap
dans les écoles et les établissements
partout sur le territoire.
Pour la rentrée deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
3000 postes D'asosh supplémentaires seront créés.
4000 postes
avaient déjà été créés aux rentrées scolaires 22 et 23.
Il s'agit là d'une mobilisation qui est très forte,
durable, des moyens de l'État pour faire de l'inclusion
1 réalité. Face à la diversité des
situations qui nécessitent chacune
1 réponse adaptée,
d'autres leviers qualitatifs doivent être mobilisés,
tant d'un point de vue organisationnel
qu'en matière de ressources humaines.
La création des pôles inclusives d'accompagnement
localisées, les piales que vous avez évoquées
en deux-mille-dix-neuf et leur
généralisation progressive
achevée depuis deux-mille-vingt-deux,
offre 1 plus grande souplesse d'organisation
au plus près des besoins quotidien de chaque élève.
De nombreuses mesures ont été prises récemment
pour revaloriser les aesh.
Depuis la rentrée 23,
c'est ainsi 1 enveloppe de deux-cent-quarante
1.000.000 d'euros qui a été
mobilisée pour permettre
1 grille indissière revalorisée
et la majoration de 10%
de l'indemnité versée aux aeush référents
qui apportent 1 appui méthodologique
et 1 soutien spécifique
aux aeush. Nouvelement nommé
depuis la rentrée 23,
les ush peuvent accéder aussi à 1 CDI
à l'issue d'un 1ère contrat
de 3 ans en cette qualité,
contre 6 ans auparavant.
Le ministère est déterminé à continuer
dans cette voie de la
professionnalisation et de l'amélioration des
conditions de rémunération des aosh
en permettant à celles et ceux qui le souhaitent
de bénéficier d'un contrat à temps complet.
Il s'agissant de la situation
particulière que vous avez évoquée,
mes pensées vont bien évidemment vers la famille de
Clotilde.
Le ministère est en lien avec l'académie.
De Paris, pour apporter,
euh, 1 réponse
à leurs attentes légitimes.
Je vous remercie.
Merci, madame la ministre.
Vous avez encore 1 peu de temps. Monsieur le. Depuis 2.
Oui, madame la ministre,
je vous remercie de cette réponse,
même si elle ne répond pas réellement à la question.
Vous me dites encore 1 fois
ce qui a été fait,
et vous nous faites encore 1 satisfaisite
comme d'habitude sur l'action du gouvernement.
Je vous parle de détresse, je vous parle de difficulté,
1 difficulté qui touche tous les,
tous les agents de votre ministère.
Je vous rappelle quand-même que,
à la on vient de l'apprendre, là, y a 4 jours,
votre ministère a rendu à Bercy
deux-cent-quatre-vingt-cinq
1.000.000 six-cent-dix-huit-mille-cent-cinquante euros,
cent-cinquante-et-un euros, pardon, et c23,
ce qui correspond en gros à 10.000 postes.
Donc, moi, j'aimerais que vous m'expliquez ce chiffre,
pourquoi il n'est-il pas possible de revaloriser
réellement les Ash,
mais également les enseignants,
alors que vous rendez de l'argent à Bercy ?
Et puis, puisque vous parlez des Ash,
puisque vous parlez des enseignants,
moi, je voudrais vous citer 1 petit peu,
vous nous avez dit,
le sujet, c'est la passion, c'est l'investissement,
le volume d'heure que chaque semaine je m'enfourne,
je ne suis pas bien payé,
euh, il faut prioriser le bien-être.
Vous avez dit que la réalité vous donne tort,
et bien oui, madame la ministre,
la réalité vous donne tort.
Vous avez dit également, ce n'est pas vous qui comptez,
c'est l'école,
je suis d'accord.
Avec vous,
vous avez dit que vous croyez en l'école publique,
alors s'il vous plaît,
pour le bien de l'école publique,
apportez de vraies réponses ou partez.
Je vous remercie.
Merci, monsieur le député.